N
ALLOWING RICO
TE LED BY YOU,
EXTEURL
NOT TO MENTIONS ALL OV
THE COUNTRY, INCLUDINGS I'
E HEN , UPSET OU.
THIS DELAY HAS A REAL IMPACT.
I TAKE AN FROM ROBINTH MORNING,
HED LASSHEATH ROBINSON, WHAF H
NC E VETERAN
RALDFY UNDER THIEALT
BILL. HT THE DELAWN
LIFE BECAUSE HE WANTSP
TIRO BE CLEAR, SHE'S TALKING
ABOUT A PREVIOUS DELAY, NOT THE
ONE YOU CAUSASEK. DY NDIBO THAT
NEED TO MIND,
RS ALL, THIS IS THDEST
TRIC WA SYMPATHETI
I  WITH ANNESS, IT
VICTIMS OF CRIME, IT D BE VETE
PROBLEMS AND THEN SNEAK IN
SOMETHING  UNRELATED
THAT THEY KNOW COULDEVERS ON IT
FFORTS, MY RN --T OW WHAT SHOULN
THE BILL LASTMOH.
AND WEERPRULD
THEN, OFOUHAT WAITFFER AN ENDMED
.
SO,
TO BE SOALS.
E  CLE
REPUBLICANS ARE NOPOSE OF THEF
P.A.C.T. ACT.
DEMOCRLLES
Y OBJECTION,
AND IF M GET M
CHANGE,  WILCHANGE BONNNY SPEND.
WHAT I CHANGE
A GOVERNMENTCCOUNTING
METHODOLOGY DESIGNED TLOW
OUR DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES TO G
ON AN UNRELATE BILLION
THTRYINGDO.RG WON'T BE
THIS THEY COULD IS A MONTHGO
WE RESOLVE THIS WITHN
ENDMENT  BDEMOCRATS ENDMENT VOTV
THE MY QUESTION IS, IF YOUT VONR
WING THEIL CORDST VOTE FOR  OUR
SENAR TOOMEY WILL VOTE
LET'S BE CLEART  WOR A VOTE ON F
STRIP OUT THIS
ION, I WILL  FBILL.
SO, THAT'S N
LOOK, CLOTURE IS N
THE BILL.
WHAT CLOTURE VOT
N BE NO MORE AMEND VOTES
I  WOUPLE OF AMENDME
ALLOWED NO AMENDMENT
THE VA IN,, I THINK WE OUG TO HN
CONSERED BECAUSE I THINK THI I
A  JAKE.
W,WAS THISTO HIS STAFF ARE
WORKING IN GOOD FAITWI
GET TO A
N' CHANGAY,
ANYTHING.
WE DON'T HAVANY MOREAT
ENTS, WE'RE  TO
HROUGH.
THE SOURCE OF
TENSION.
>> BS NOT ENOUGH YOU
A VOTOUR ENT.
YOU WANT YOUR BL
VOTES ON THEIR
HT  I DO THI A
THAT PS TWO OR THREE
ENT TES.
>> WE'LL SEE IF OUR DEMOCRIC IPT
ANT TOBILL.
>> THE TOPCAN ON THE
SE VETERANAFIR SENATORORF
KANSAS, HE SAYS HE THINKS
REPUBLICANS SHOULD PASS THIS NOW
AND FIX ANY PROBLEMS THAT EMERGN
LATER.HY THEY'RE NOTG
THE OPPORTUNITY NOW.
THEY KNOW ANS
>> ONE OS I THINK
PEOPLE HAVE ABOUWH YA BUDGETARY
IS THE VA BUDGETS WILL ALWAYS
TH CTHIS MONEYY THEY
-- HOWD THIS IHAE SPLTH
CARE FOR
EXITS.
OF THINGKE GETS HI
VERY DEEP IN THE WEEDS AND VERY
QUKL
IT'S REALLABTERANSDI.HAT GOF OOT
NO AFFECT IN. CHANGE,T PEOPLE
MONEY FOR BEINDER WHICH THE
PUT WHTOIS TREAT GOVERNMENACCOU
ACCOUNTING PURPOSENGE IT TO THEE
DEMOCRATS WANT CREESOOM URE BU
BILLION OF TOTALLY U
EXTRANEOUS SIN OTHER
THAT'S WHAWAPREVENT.
WE ARE SPENDING WAY TOO MUCH